[Música]
qué fuimos puse acusan de crímenes de
guerra Ucrania declara haber encontrado
cuatro cámaras de tortura en gerson tras
La retirada de las tropas rusas y la ONU
Investiga el presunto asesinato de
soldados rusos rendidos por parte del
ejército ucraniano Tenemos reporte en
esta edición
Andrés Manuel López Obrador suspende la
Cumbre del Pacífico en México porque el
congreso de Perú impide viajar al
presidente Pedro Castillo Y el
mandatario peruano apoya a hacer la
reunión en su país mientras la oea se
encuentra en Perú para investigar el
conflicto entre el legislativo y El
Ejecutivo de Lima
Vladimir Putin recibió a Miguel Díaz
canel en Moscú el presidente de Rusia y
el de Cuba inauguraron un monumento a
Fidel Castro en la capital rusa el mismo
día en que Putin dio a conocer sus dos
nuevos rompehielos nucleares para
dominar el Ártico
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relativa a la guerra en Ucrania porque
Moscú y kiev se acusan mutuamente de
crímenes de guerra por un lado la ONU
Investiga el presunto asesinato por
parte de las fuerzas ucranianas de 10
soldados rusos que se habrían rendido en
lugansk las autoridades de kiev tildan
de montaje las imágenes del crimen que
sin embargo Fueron verificadas por el
New York Times por otro lado el ejército
de Ucrania declaró haber encontrado
cuatro cámaras de tortura en la ciudad
de gerson tras La retirada de las
fuerzas de Moscú y precisamente allí en
gerson está nuestra corresponsal
Catalina Gómez Ángel que nos reporta
sobre la situación de los civiles en
esta urbe a pocos metros del frente de
la guerra
este es uno de los peligros que afronta
persona en este momento está en poder de
las tropas ucranianas pero solamente
cruzando el río en hiper que está detrás
nuestro están ya las posiciones rusas
por eso los constantes ataques que oímos
permanentemente de artillería también se
oye en drones y la población obviamente
se siente tranquila en el sentido de que
las tropas ucranianas están en el
control no tienen a los rusos caminando
por la calle esperando que vengan a sus
casas pero al mismo tiempo lo sienten
muy cerca y por eso El clamor general es
que quieren la paz que que sus hombres
estén bien que puedan terminar esta
guerra con Victoria para Ucrania todos
dicen somos ucranianos sin embargo el
temor aquí es bastante grande y otro
temor que se suma es el de personas
cercanas o colaboradoras
Rusia hay o que colaboraron con ellos en
su momento y que se quedaron en la
ciudad ese es otro factor de temor de la
población y también de las tropas
ucranianas y por eso también tienen el
control de seguridad y de acceso a la
ciudad bastante limitado como se ve
también en los retenes a la entrada de
la ciudad Así que este río atrás nuestro
es uno es un elemento de protección pero
también de inseguridad porque atrás
están los rusos
y las luchas geopolíticas se expanden
Más allá de la Guerra de Ucrania Este
martes el presidente de Rusia Vladimir
Putin inauguró dos barcos rompehielos de
propulsión nuclear con los que pretende
afianzar su liderazgo en el Ártico para
explotar los recursos naturales y abrir
rutas marítimas
el futuro pasa por el Ártico
especialmente para Rusia que este martes
inauguró dos nuevos barcos rompehielos
de propulsión nuclear el yakutia listo
para entrar en funcionamiento y el ural
que lo hará pronto
Los buques de una clase tan alta son de
importancia estratégica para nosotros
son necesarios para el estudio y
desarrollo del Ártico para garantizar
una navegación segura y sostenible en
esta región aumentando el tráfico a lo
largo de la ruta del mar del Norte en el
consejo del artículo hay presencia de 8
países Dinamarca Islandia Noruega Suecia
Finlandia Rusia Canadá y Estados Unidos
casi todos menos Rusia forman parte de
la otan Suecia y Finlandia han pedido
acceso al bloque se cree que en el
Ártico hay un 25% de reservas mundiales
de varios recursos naturales Mientras
que el deshielo causado por la crisis
climática podría abrir nuevas rutas
marítimas hasta semanas más rápidas
con el derretimiento de la capa de hielo
ha habido una gran discusión entre los
estados árticos y no árticos sobre el
potencial económico todo desde el acceso
a los suministros de energía los metales
y minerales y hasta la apertura de
nuevas rutas de navegación
su control es estratégico y Moscú lleva
la delantera los analistas creen que
occidente necesita 10 años para ponerse
al día con el ejército ruso en la región
Rusia cuenta con infraestructura
portuaria desarrollo tecnológico y
extensión geográfica por lo que trata de
imponer sus propias reglas en la zona
desde antes de 2014 queríamos más
actividad aliada en el norte queríamos
que la otan vigilara también en el norte
tener una vista de 360 grados desde el
Ártico que la otan incluyera el Ártico
Entonces
desde 2005 Rusia reabierto decenas de
bases militares de la era soviética en
el Ártico donde tiene soberanía en más
de 24.000 kilómetros de Costa el
presidente Vladimir Putin recibió en
Moscú a su homólogo cubano Miguel Díaz
canel quien lleva a cabo una gira
internacional que empezó en Argelia y lo
llevará también a Turquía y a China
entre otras cuestiones el gobierno de La
Habana expresó su intención de importar
hidrocarburos desde Rusia ambos
mandatarios inauguraron en la capital
rusa un monumento en honor a Fidel
Castro a quien Putin reconoció haber
establecido una amistad histórica con la
unión soviética además Putin aseguró que
el kremlin defiende la soberanía de Cuba
y denuncia el embargo de Estados Unidos
sobre la isla y que agradece el mismo
respaldo a Rusia por parte de Cuba
Cuba enérgicamente
las sanciones que hoy se imponen de
manera unilateral e injusta a la
federación de Rusia
las causas del conflicto actual en esta
zona hay que buscarlas en la política
agresiva de Estados Unidos y en la
expansión del otan hacia la fronteras de
Rusia lo que Cuba ha denunciado de
manera sistemática en foros
internacionales
Cuba como ha expresado en muchas
oportunidades se pronuncia por una
solución negociada al actual conflicto
en Irán la central nuclear de fortdown
está enriqueciendo uranio al 60%, 16
veces más que el umbral de 3,67
permitido en el acuerdo nuclear de 2015
del que Washington se retiró en 2018 a
la oea le preocupa que Teherán esté cada
vez más cerca de crear una bomba nuclear
lejos de un consenso entreterano y
occidente en la escalada nuclear sigue
en Irán Ahora hay una nueva central que
enriquecerá uranio al 60%, la de fortdow
en las afueras de Teherán
como respuesta a la resolución de la
junta de gobernadores la organización de
la energía atómica de Irán ha
incrementado el uranio al 60% en la
central nuclear de fortdow Y es que la
ya tensa relación entre Irán Angelo y ea
se ha complicado después de que el
organismo decidiera respaldar una
resolución propuesta por Estados Unidos
a Francia Reino Unido y Alemania en la
que se exige facilitar explicaciones
técnicas creíbles después de descubrir
restos de uranio entre su ubicaciones a
no declaradas acusaciones que Teherán ha
rechazado ya tachado de anti iraníes Y
políticamente motivadas
cómo Irán ha señalado en repetidas
ocasiones la razón por la que las
negociaciones no han llegado a su fin y
las partes implicadas no pueden reanudar
el acuerdo nuclear es obviamente porque
Estados Unidos carece de voluntad
política
eran dispone de una reserva de entorno a
3673 kilogramos de uranio enriquecido en
diferentes purezas del 2% 5% un 20% y 60
por ciento frente al máximo de 300
kilogramos y una pureza máxima de
3,67%. permitida bajo el acuerdo nuclear
de 2015 que Estados Unidos abandonó
unilateralmente bajo la administración
de Donald Trump en 2018 y que Irán dejó
de cumplir progresivamente
eloía asegura que Irán está solo a un
pequeño paso técnico para enriquecer
uranio al 90%. un umbral necesario para
fabricar una arma nuclear además Irán ya
ha asegurado que no piensa volver a las
negociaciones para revivir el acuerdo
nuclear si occidente no retira las
acusaciones en su contra y China no deja
atrás las medidas restrictivas por la
pandemia de Kobe 19 las autoridades
volvieron a decretar cierres de locales
de ocio en la capital tras el rebrote de
los casos nuestro corresponsal en
Beijing Adrián foncillas con los
detalles
sufre el peor brote desde que empezó la
pandemia los casos han subido en los
últimos tres días desde los 600 a los
1000 hasta los 1.400 y eso a pesar de
las crecientes restricciones hoy Beijing
ha cerrado centros comerciales museos y
parques y además impone una cuarentena
de tres días a todos los que llegan a la
ciudad el viernes ya había empezado a
cerrar bares y restaurantes que ahora
solo pueden servir comida a domicilio
además muchos lugares públicos exigen
una prueba pcr realizada en las últimas
24 horas encontrarte con las 72
habituales lo que explica las largas
colas Para hacerse los test de Jim vive
en un estado de Semi confinamiento con
cada vez más complejos inmobiliarios
puestos en cuarentena ninguna de las
noticias que llega desde la capital son
positivas este fin de semana se informó
de tres muertos todos ellos octogenarios
y con enfermedades previas pero son los
primeros muertos por Kobe que china en
seis meses es también la primera vez en
ese plazo que el país roza los 30.000
casos diarios fue en aquel brote
gigantesco que obligó a cerrar Shanghai
durante casi tres meses Pero la
situación ahora es más preocupante
porque los contagios están repartidos
por varias ciudades el caso de chonchin
en el centro o de wanjoo en el sur que
no han podido en bridar sus brotes
durante semanas a pesar de todas las
restricciones aprobadas
el presidente peruano Pedro Castillo da
su apoyo a que la Cumbre de la alianza
del Pacífico se celebra en Perú es que
recordemos que el presidente mexicano
suspendió el encuentro previsto para
este viernes en México como medida de
solidaridad con el presidente Castillo
aquí en el congreso de Perú le impidió
viajar conectamos ahora con nuestro
corresponsal Francisco Zacarías
Francisco Buenas tardes Cuáles son las
reacciones tras a la noticia de la
suspensión de la cumbre en México y la
posibilidad de que se celebra en Perú
buenas tardes Le comento que el
presidente Pedro Castillo se mostró muy
agradecido y contento de que los
mandatarios de la alianza del Pacífico
vengan a hacer una muy probable reunión
pronto para entregarle la presidencia
protempore del bloque regional al
mandatario peruano y que después se
realice una cumbre de presidentes de
Chile Colombia y México Pedro Castillo
ha señalado esta dispuesto a recibir a
los presidentes de la alianza del
Pacífico los espera con los brazos
abiertos si es que ellos desean realizar
una visita anticipada en los siguientes
días ha señalado hay que recordar que el
pasado jueves 17 de noviembre el
congreso peruano le negó al mandatario
peruano una visita a México para esta
importante Cumbre esto ha motivado que
el presidente mexicano Manuel López
Obrador decidiera Cancelar esta
importante Cumbre hay que señalar el
otro lado que Pedro Castillo enfrenta
una crisis política que ya lleva varios
meses en del país el también tiene
sobre sus hombros El Seis acusaciones
por corrupción y la verdad que este
hecho que vengan los presidentes en
México Colombia y chile representa para
Pedro Castillo un respaldo internacional
en momentos en que más lo necesita y
Francisco como avanza la misión de la
oea que Investiga a petición de Castillo
esta crisis que usted nos reporta entre
el legislativo y El Ejecutivo
Sí justamente la comisión de alto nivel
de la organización de los Estados
Americanos atendiendo a la activación de
la carta democrática Interamericana está
llevando su segundo día de reuniones en
la cual esta cita culmina hoy en este
país y hasta el momento se ha reunido
con los integrantes del gobierno del
presidente Pedro Castillo los líderes
del parlamento peruano en la jefa del
poder judicial así como la fiscal
general de Perú entre otras integrantes
de la sociedad civil peruana el
presidente del poder legislativo José
Williams ha reconocido que existe
fricciones con el gobierno de Pedro
Castillo Pero ha negado que el
parlamento peruano esté tratando de
producir un golpe de estado en este país
para derrocarlo por su parte Pedro
Castillo le ha dicho a la comisión de
alto nivel que él mantendrá el diálogo
permanente con todas las instituciones
del país para tratar de solucionar esta
crisis que mantiene paralizada esta
nación hay que señalar también que El
Vocero del grupo alto nivel Eladio
loizaga ha afirmado que los diálogos son
transparentes y que las conclusiones
serán dadas a conocer a la comisión
permanente de la oea en los próximos
días Francisco Muchas gracias por el
reporte continuamos pendientes a estas
crisis abiertas en Perú
y en otras noticias falleció a sus 79
años Pablo Milanés uno de los fundadores
del movimiento de la nueva Trova en Cuba
que recorrió el mundo como embajador
cultural de la revolución de Fidel
Castro el artista murió en España Donde
había estado bajo tratamiento por un
tipo de cáncer en la sangre Milanés Era
uno de los cantautores cubanos de mayor
proyección internacional titular de
éxitos como Yolanda yo me quedo y amo
esta isla y así llegamos al final de
esta edición informativa sigan con
nosotros
[Música]